30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play
today is going to be an explosive
kickboxing workout to blast fat so it's
going to be working on your total body
we want to combine kickboxing moves with
bodyweight exercises so throughout this
workout I want you to have fun keep up
with me and just enjoy the flow okay
[Music]
so let's start with a quick warm-up to
loosen up your joints let's start by
standing shoulder width apart with your
toes pointed forward and I want you to
squat down and straighten your legs just
to stretch out the hamstrings okay so
straighten up down and up down and up
good let's do five more okay keeping
your chest up nice down let's go deeper
down and up last two more one more and
good okay now let's get into some
reverse lunges step back forward and the
other side very good reverse lunges just
to really open up the hip flexor and now
give me two more with a knee up alright
on one side and now switch knee up good
knee up and last one good and now what I
want to do is just loosen up your hip
flexor okay with key boxing movements
you will be using a lot of work on your
hip flexor especially at the twisting
motion and the pivoting movements
alright so just open up try to bring it
as high as you can point your toes down
open it up good keep going last two more
hands up let's get ready in our kick
boxing stance last one and good okay now
step back what I'm going to do is slowly
inch forward keeping your leg straight
to stretch out your hamstring into a
plank
give me one push-up and now slowly inch
forward inch back still keeping your
legs straight okay as much as you can
slowly inch forward feel the stretching
hamstring in a glute push up and back
alright and stand up stretch up let's go
for one more inch forward push up inch
back
and as you come up stretch up very good
okay so let's get into the first workout
the first workout it's going to be a jab
and across okay so for the first round I
want you to focus on the right technique
and on the second round we want to add
on another exercise okay
so again step your left leg forward
right leg back just keep your base
really fluid okay and both arms up
give me a jab and a punch okay jab and a
cross there you go
remember the power should be coming from
your hips and your shoulders instead of
your arms all right so Jeff punch let's
start easy okay jab and cross good and
aim at one point cross it pivot pivot
and pivot good twist your hips feel the
strength and the momentum coming from
your hips okay so at all points do not
drop your arms throughout the workout I
want you to keep your arms up guarding
your face okay so twist and good jab
cross as you get used to the movement
you can spin it up jab cross
oh good and now rest it up next we want
to add on another exercise so Jeff cross
what I want to do is switch over switch
up jab cross down switch okay let's go
jab cross down into a squat back up jab
cross down squat switch over and up
pivoting on your toes good come on move
those hips and up nice remember do not
drop your arms all right it should be up
guarding your face because there let's
say someone will hit you you can protect
yourself nice
keep going at least two more up jab
cross dunk feel your legs burning one
more let's go don't push your butt back
jab cross and rest it out okay Second
Circuit okay
front kicks again left leg forward right
leg back
throw me a front kick and with your
right leg throw me another front kid
okay
always getting back into this stance
let's go front kick kick it good imagine
you're kicking at the mid part of your
food okay at the ball of your food
basically three runs down Tori arms down
whichever foot you're kicking with drive
your arms down to even to give you more
energy basically take it forward
good let me hear that sound whoa good
high kick it high lean back slightly
type in a car use your car and remember
again I'm a bouquet one arm stay up all
the time
and keep your movement fluid click
alright keep your post light good next
progression so again front kick but this
time what are we to do is kick and I
want to step back into illogically so
study the lunge kick stop in the middle
step back and kick good so let's start
in this position step back lunge kick
back and lunge kick good so stepping
into a reverse lunge and kick good
reverse lunge kick dropping the arm and
cake
reverse lunge kick good reverse and cake
let's drive a knee down close to the
floor stop Kate let's step cake good
right leg kick nice left side let's spit
it up right by speed it up kick last one
Lauren kick keep going and rest it out
very good okay third second okay
shuffle it's really simple it's just
moving your
and right leg forward and back okay what
I want to make sure is that you're
keeping your body soft I'm up and you're
really working on your calf muscles okay
so you can either choose to speed it up
shuffling forward and back
remember do not twist okay no twisting
keeping your body forward or you can
slow it down slightly and use this as
your active recovery so shuffle forward
and back good again the weight should be
on the ball of your foot okay good keep
going shuffling keeping your arms up
show this up guard in your face look
straight ahead move your hips good last
few more and break okay progression what
I want to do now is shuffle left and
right twice each get down into a sprawl
hips touching the ground come back up
and back into shuffle okay left and
right is one ready arms up all the time
let's go to down into a sprawl hips
touching the floor back up let's go left
there right sprawl good up nice breathe
that's getting to sprawl up let's
fathers you can roll down kick back and
back up
can you feel your heart rate pumping
mine is rocket high keep going up at
least two more okay ah
stay strong arms up do not drop your
arms right now
up one two down into ass problem come
back up and
rest all right it's a good deep breath
let's get back into some upper body work
okay I'm up back again into your
fighting stance okay what I want to do
is give me a hook hook so imagine you're
punching and hitting someone on the side
okay so maintaining the arms hook
twist twist you know the more you pivot
and the more you twist the stronger your
hooks will be good keep going
twist twist arms close to your face okay
close your elbows do not open it this is
wrong
keep it close hook and hook keeping a
tight hook hook the tighter you keep
yourself the better you will be at
guarding your face and your body as well
okay okay okay okay okay good pivot
twist last one rest it okay progression
you know what's next
okay so what I want to do now is give me
a left and right hook
give me a roundhouse kick on the right
side switch and another roundhouse kick
on the left side okay it's not at a
comfortable level let's go hook hook
right fly roundhouse kick step back
switch left side and step forward right
leg back okay hook hook right pivot
switch left pivot good let's go hook
okay
if you kick get on to your toes switch
cake pull you back good hook hook kick
pull back switch kick and pull back nice
few more okay keep it fluid kick keep it
going switch kick and one more come on
strong hooks cake on the right side back
switch kick okay all right rest it off
ten more seconds okay elbow strikes
again starting Fighting's thanks okay
with elbow all I need to do is lift your
arms up elbow and twist
the pumps facing out okay so twist
imagine you're striking someone with an
elbow with your a ball a strike elbow
should be facing front strike strike
again pivoting okay keeping your lower
body nice and easy okay elbow point
again right in the center okay you
remember the tip is to twist with the
pumps facing out so twist pumps facing
up and pivot all right move your hips
remember with every movement you want to
be working on your hips to drive the
power and energy good twist it twist it
strike someone right in the face
good few more let's get going keeping
your lower body moving twist and good
elbow strikes and rest it on okay
progression all right this is good to
include a little bit of explosive body
ready to work out so - elbow strikes get
me give me two explosive lunges back up
two strikes
down up and back down good stand up
elbow strikes back down whoa let's work
the lower body and down good very good
strike
good strong arms strong lower body okay
I told you it's a total body workout
down switch and up good halfway there
okay
keep going up strike you down and keep
it up last few more up elbow strikes
give me one more switch switch up strike
strike and rest it aha take one final
workout okay want to find a workout and
you again in one minute Rick nice all
right so with this again left leg
forward right leg back
I want it to drive your knees forward
okay and step back switch side drive it
forward remember it's all about the
movement on your hips so drive it
forward push it up drive it on your toes
okay so
imagine your hips should be moving
moving forward not up okay
forward good drive it push it good so
imagine you're grabbing your opponent
and giving him a really strong knee
that's it grab you only showed us and me
good so again imagine you're grabbing
the person whoa explosive power whoo
good job then you go again
good driving forward okay if you're
gonna hit up you're gonna probably miss
it again
forward and forward all right good let's
go for the next progression okay so nice
again
left-right and what I want to add on is
a side kick with a slight kick okay
that's it simple let's go left and right
step back
sidekick sidekick good again forward
good drive it knees strike strong
sidekicks strong sidekicks if you want
you can drop your arms okay let's go
forward
woo go BAM kick drop it for the extra
power go strike forward strike cake cake
good remember to use a car to pull your
legs back okay so kick it pull it back
kick it holy back good last one more
whoo
kick it pull it back kick in play back
and rest
alright I'm absolutely sweaty take this
one-minute break to breathe keep
yourself hydrated wipe your sweat and we
want to repeat the entire kickboxing
circuit once more okay
my heart rate is like going crazy right
now it's at at least 160 to 170 heart
rate per minute it's going crazy but
that's what you want to increase your
heart rate to maximize fat burn and to
also stop your muscles okay all right
you have less than 10 seconds okay let's
get into your fighting stance left leg
forward right leg back first jump and
cross okay start with the basic get this
right and you will be able to progress
quicker okay good so remember the power
is from your hips and your shoulders
okay so imagine you're shrugging your
shoulders keeping it up and your
shoulders should also be guarding your
face okay as you jump and punch your
shoulders should be close to your face
let's go jab and cross jab and cross you
do not do this or do not drop one hand
as you punch okay this is wrong keeping
it up punch it twist your hips pivot on
your toes quick piven quick let's go
fast jab cross good jab cross good
another one jab cross and wrap it up
okay
jab cross with a switch okay
I want to work on your lower body your
legs and your glutes alright so take a
deep breath in and let's start with your
jab cross and switch okay keep your
lower body light and easy jab cross good
always on your toes okay jab cross good
keeping your light and fast jab cross
nice keep going switch
who done it up push it back if at all
you feel like you need to take a shower
breather go ahead okay it's all about
working at your own speed okay if you
can do not stop and just get into jab
cross without the explosive switch jab
cross switch last one up jab cross and
rest it on alright from cakes okay again
fighting stance you should know it by
now
left right behind it should be squared
so do not twist too much to the side
okay skirt to the front okay so let's go
Frank quick left stop be back right step
back
keep it fluid left and right okay always
moving on your toes it's not about
rushing the workout I want to see that
fluid movement okay so always keeping
yourself on your toes keeping yourself
really light good Frankie
guys back whoa front as high as you can
tighten a car suck your belly in drive
your legs back fast nice few more huh
that's two more one more
let's go left and right all right okay
so now front kicks with explosive with
lunges okay not explosive lunges just
line just around okay so let's start
with your left leg reverse lunges okay
so step back into a front kick keep it
light right leg back left kick dropping
the opposite arm okay so left back good
one up one arm should always be up left
back kick it up nice right back
let's spit it up right switching
consistently keep going last 15 seconds
sorry to switch path kick it
drive it back switch kick drive it back
left leg kick and right whoa strong
front kick laughs ah
take a shot break okay shuffle all right
working mainly on your cuffs all right
choose to take this as your active rest
or if you want to keep pushing let's go
shuffle okay if you want to use this as
your active press then go slow okay
shuffling forward and back again keeping
yourself light if you are ready to fight
then I'm sorry
okay this is to practice your feet
movement okay and that's why I kick
boxes they do this it's to make sure
that they're moving is fluid and it's
quickly on their toes good keep going
you have ten more seconds
all right and we want to move on with
shuffles and sprawl okay keep going fast
on your feet and rest okay remember the
goal is to drive your hips onto the
floor okay get your hips touching the
floor two shuffles with one sprawl okay
I'm up ready breathe in and let's go one
two down hips onto the floor up bust
down and back up
good there you go remember to pace your
breathing throughout up down
into ass prompt using your arms to push
yourself back up
don't endorse bro keep back straight up
crunch your core ok as you hop both legs
back in and keep going whoa sprung and
back up back down good last one more one
last bro come on you got this and rest
it out alright let's get back onto our
upper body ok hooks and hooks okay
remember the goal is to hit or punch
someone on the side okay let's go hook
hook again with punches and hook the
more you pivot the more you use the
strength from your hips the more power
you will have so the strength doesn't
come from your arms it comes from your
hips pivoting to is good get in contact
nice and looking straight ahead okay
hook hook looking straight ahead keeping
your body tight alright do not spread
our elbows so this is wrong
keep your elbows close hook hook and go
come on do not drop the arms once you
have hooked can be back and back nice
the last five seconds you've got this
you're strong breathe that's one more
oh you are almost there
hook hooks with roundhouse kicks okay
so start with your right leg switch to
your left side alright so step back
breathe let's go hook hook find your
comfortable point switch and kick if you
can't kick too high that's fine okay the
goal is to make sure that you can
balance yourself with a core bring your
back switch over and find that balance
okay I want I don't want you to be
wobbly hook hook let's go kick it find
the balance swap kick and switch back
hook hook nice
up dropping the opposite hand switch
drop and back huh who's with me
kick swamp and cake
good glass hooks give me two strong
roundhouse kick pull it back pull it
back very good
okay breathe in and breathe out elbow
strikes so what is the most important
tip when you strike with the elbow it's
about cutting someone through the middle
of their face hitting and breaking their
nose okay so with your elbows cut it
that person with the elbow strike palms
facing out and you go okay so twist with
the palms facing out and driving through
the mid part of that person's face your
opponent's face alright and again
keeping your body tight at all time okay
so do not drop into a strike keeping it
up and straight strike strike good and
again tipping your lower body moving
okay don't rush the workout well it's
more important is that you're staying on
your toes constantly and you're moving
fast good all right strike whoa hit come
on strong elbow strikes use those elbows
very good and you will also be working
on your triceps okay so two elbow
strikes left and right each with
explosive lunges okay all right strong
legs back onto our legs and go left
right down explode explode back up onto
your toes strike it good done explode
and back up whoop strike back dad you
are stronger this is your final second
workout okay keep going strike strike
down keeping your arms up do not drop it
right now if you're struggling you can
always take a step back and back okay
find your rhythm but I want you to keep
going
down up
ten more seconds ah last one last
explosive I'm just up up and rest it off
oh my god what what finer round okay
one final round of knee strikes okay and
remember it's about driving your knees
forward not up okay remember keeping
your toes and drive it up
imagine you're grabbing the person drive
it forward step back find your rhythm
step back and drive okay
do not rush whoa drive it crap and near
the other person if you want to you can
add a little bit of hop oh good
imagine you're grabbing and drive
straight into the our chorus section
okay forward step back and forward good
tipping your arms up grab and dry grab
drive nice step back and drive okay
every time you step back use the power
to move your body forward and strike it
okay oh one find a workout okay
knee strikes with five kicks okay left
and right all right breathe in and
breathe out 45 seconds left let's go
drive pull it and now I wait to kick to
the side use your core to drive it's
half back and good left knee right knee
cake drop your arms drop your back cake
on the side good drive and drive you
remember it's not a lake race okay it's
a proper cake and take good left and
right whoop step back kick drop it
and kick nice feel the outer thighs
working as well as your core and inner
thighs huh kickboxing is such a good
total body career because it works your
body from all angles
forward and also the side and back
oh okay take a deep breath in breathe
out and just get into a child's pose
okay bring your heart rate down
stretch your body out
I thought you it's going to be an
explosive cardio kickboxing workout I
will not let you walk out of this door
without getting drenched
I love kickboxing as my cardio because
it works your entire body you're moving
from all different angles it works on
your car it works on your balance and
you will also be sculpting your muscles
so do this workout at least two to three
times weekly and combine this with my
other strength training workout on my
youtube channel and I can assure you you
will be losing weight so be sure to hit
the like button share this workout and
also subscribe to my youtube channel and
I will see you in my next threat the
session all the best